Танки, ракетні системи та десятки тисяч військовослужбовців, які оточили Україну з півночі та півдня.
Офіційно це були звичайні навчання. А насправді - одна з найбільших мобілізацій російських збройних сил останніх десятиліть.
І Москва не намагалась це приховати.
У будь-якій конфліктній ситуації пан Путін намагається нагадати західним колегам, що він може легко спалити планету.
А потім, через кілька тижнів, все закінчилося. Так само раптово, як і почалося.
Міноборони Росії оголосило, що всі війська повернуться на базу. Але при цьому концентрація військ майже не змінилася.
То що саме робить Росія? До чого ця величезна демонстрація сили від Путіна? Давайте дізнаємось.
Йдеться про Україну, розчарування Москви щодо Зеленського, сподівання в Москві, що він піде на поступки.
Але я думаю, що це також тест на те, як відреагує Захід і, зокрема, адміністрація Байдена.
Ну, і просто спосіб нагадати людям, що Росія, в принципі, готова використовувати військовий інструментарій.
Безумовно, за попередника Байдена, Дональда Трампа, уваги та демонстративних проявів поваги до Путіна не бракувало.
Їхній - зрештою безрезультатний - саміт у Гельсінкі нагадав багатьом спостерігачам про дипломатію "холодної війни" 70-их,
а не про зустріч лідера супердержави з країною, економіка якої удесятеро менша.
Коли Трампа обирали, люди в Москві святкували, стріляючи корками від шампанського...
Коли обрали Байдена, цього точно не було.
Не думаю, що Путін розраховує отримати те, що отримав від Трампа, який, між іншим, казав, що більше довіряє Путіну, ніж американським спецслужбам.
Новий президент США, який ще до адміністрації Обами кілька десятиліть був членом комітету закордонних справ Сенату, обрав зовсім інший тон.
Отже, ви знаєте Володимира Путіна. Думаєте, він - вбивця?
- Так.
Це викликало реакцію, жорстку навіть за мірками Кремля.
Хто як обзивається, той так і називається. Ми завжди в іншому бачимо власні якості і думаємо, що він такий самий, як ми.
Здавалося б, одне коротке "так" від нового президента США справді вкололо, як жодні численні порції санкцій.
Не в особистому плані, а тому, що це передбачало дещо ширше - спробу дипломатичної ізоляції Кремля.
Мовляв, є лідер, з яким Захід не може вести справи.
Через кілька днів вже їхали російські танки. Спочатку невеликими групами, це видавалося за звичайні навчання.
Потім більше й більше, змушуючи колишніх генералів НАТО вголос непокоїтися про загрозу вторгнення Росії в Україну.
Думаю, що, ймовірно, були різні сценарії. І я не впевнена, що вони з самого початку вирішили, що не будуть атакувати за жодних обставин.
В моєму уявленні, головною метою цих навчань було створити нову розмінну монету для розмови з Заходом.
Цією розмінною монетою буде можливість війни в Україні.
Олександр Гольц переконаний, що за цими пересуваннями військ стояла політика, а не військова загроза з боку НАТО,
і насправді саме Росія своїми бойовими діями у 2014 році змусила НАТО реально взаємодіяти з Україною.
Для мене абсолютно ясно, що військові НАТО розпочали своє розміщення після 2014 року.
Україна закликала своїх військових - і повторювала це мантроподібно – не дозволяти провокувати себе і не стріляти першими.
Київ будь що намагався не дати привід для російського наступу. Але у багатьох цивільних на сході України речі вже були спаковані.
Тим часом американські законодавці наполягають на збільшенні підтримки українських військових до 300 мільйонів доларів на рік.
І головне - ця підтримка включатиме тепер, ймовірно, летальну зброю - протитанкові та зенітні системи, а не лише оборонне обладнання, як раніше.
Це те, на чому Україна безуспішно наполягала роками.
І європейські лідери, які раніше намагалися взаємодіяти з Росією та бути посередниками, раптом перейшли на більш рішучий тон.
Європа, заявив французький президент Еммануель Макрон, не терпітиме нових військових дій на українській території.
Однак дуже важливо те, що Європа не уточнила цінУ, яку Кремль заплатить за вторгнення в Україну.
Не було й обіцянок зупинити будівництво "Північного потоку-2".
Організатори будь-яких провокацій, що загрожують ґрунтовним інтересам нашої безпеки,
пошкодують про скоєне так, як давно вже ні про що не шкодували.
Потім відбулося з нетерпінням очікуване щорічне звернення Володимира Путіна.
У ньому було багато хизування, але напрочуд мало деталей щодо одного питання, яким переймається увесь світ.
Він майже не згадував про Україну. Наступного дня міноборони РФ оголосило про закінчення згаданих "псевдонавчань".
Чого ж насправді досягла ця дорога ескалація?
Безсумнівно, що вся ця спроба торгу була дуже успішною. Байден зателефонував, Байден пропонує зустріч.
Отже, хто скаже, що пан Путін - ізольований диктатор? Заради Бога, усі хочуть поговорити з ним.
Думаю, насправді Москва вийшла з цього з відчуттям, що вона стала сильнішою, начебто це було того варте.
Військовий інструментарій - це також те, на що Захід дуже неохоче реагує тим же.
Отже, це свого роду ідеальний інструмент - він дозволяє Росії вважати, що вона сильна, бо готова використовувати цю силу.
Як з точки зору демонстрації сили, так і з точки зору фактичних військових дій.
Існує думка, що небажання Заходу застосовувати силу зараз може насправді спонукати Володимира Путіна застосувати її.
Сусіди Росії, передусім Україна, закликають Захід змусити Путіна заплатити довгострокову політичну ціну за створення загрози війни.
Мовляв, інакше Європі доведеться звикнути до такого роду "дипломатії".